[Music]
a Wisconsin company claims it will be
the first in the country to implant
microchips in most of its employees free
square market plans to implant chips
like these in the hands of volunteers
among its workforce the technology
replaces ID cards used to open doors and
operate office equipment Jamie yuccas is
that the company's headquarters in River
Falls Wisconsin to look at the privacy
concerns raised by the plans Jamie good
morning good morning 3 Square market has
about 80 employees and the place they'll
use the technology the most is probably
right here in the break room whether
they're buying fruit snacks or maybe
some Lucky Charms in order to pay they
won't use a credit card all they'll have
to do is flick their wrist by next week
more than fifty three square Market
employees will have Bionic hands with a
credit card chip implanted near their
wrist you just swipe your hand basically
it's a serial number that is assigned to
your credit card the company is offering
the chips which cost about three hundred
dollars apiece to its employees for free
the owner Todd Westby his wife and two
children will also be getting microchip
you're not going to be tracking your
employees around town to see what
they're up to and what they're doing no
we will not it's for entrance to the
building's logging into computers making
purchases in our break room market
things of that nature it employees will
now have two ways to get into the
building they can either use the
traditional keypad with their ID number
or if their microchip they can just use
their hands and swipe that will allow
them to open the door 3 square market
makes vending machines with credit card
chip readers experts wonder if this is
all a publicity stunt and worried about
the loss of privacy you want someone
knowing every time you enter a leave a
room or use a copy machine there's a
degree of autonomy that's lost with this
you know person-to-person one-to-one
bracket you can never leave it behind
you can't really turn it off I think
it's a step towards the future but
assembly line manager Eric white things
the chips could eventually save lives
somebody who's allergic to something or
has a condition they could scan your
hand and all the information is there
the technology is already being used in
Europe but the company hoping to
popularize the
here in the u.s. is far from tech hubs
like Silicon Valley so watch out River
Falls Wisconsin might be the next big
thing and we're glad to be a part of it
three square market is working with a
Swedish company to embed the microchips
and its employees everybody wants to
know how big is it right it's the size
of a grain of rice you see that right
there a professional piercer actually
has to put it in the person's hand now
to remove it I'm told it's just like
removing a sliver the pain factor by the
way is like getting your ears pierced
Nora Wow Jamie Thank You Gail I don't
have my ears pineapple I know you're gay
I will give birth to children I will not
get my ears pierced that hole I know
it's very futuristic I get it
but I think what's wrong with just
taking out your card but good for them I
think it's the wave of the future that
we'll all have implant and chips that
have our medical records so you would do
it sure okay so you're carrying around a
phone anyway that no that you would do
it to Charlie Whedon I need to catch up
not need to catch up